la planta nuclear más grande de Europa
está en poder de Rusia desde hace
semanas bombardeos han impactado los
alrededores Pero quién es la
bombardeando ambos lados acusan
mutuamente de atacar constantemente la
planta
kiev continúa su provocación para
amenazarnos con un desastre nuclear en
saporilla
esta guerra de la información también se
puede escuchar desde el lado ucraniano
la planta fue impactada seguramente Sí
pero no está claro donde exactamente
dentro del perímetro de seguridad hay
seis reactores y áreas dedicadas al
combustible usado y a los desechos
nucleares los reactores están protegidos
pero hasta cierto punto
los edificios de contención que son
cúpulas de hormigón están ahí para
proteger el núcleo del reactor así como
la piscina donde se almacena El
combustible gastado los protegen por
ejemplo de un accidente aéreo pero no
han sido diseñados para los riesgos de
bombardeo en tiempos de guerra
algunas áreas de la central nuclear no
están tan protegidas porque son menos
peligrosas Hay riesgo de contaminación
un ataque en un área de almacenamiento
de residuos podría llevar a una difusión
más limitada y local unos kilómetros
quizás pero no al nivel nacional o
continental
nacional nacional
por el momento la agencia de seguridad
nuclea registraron un aumento de
radioactividad en el área